the european union's border agency says
illegal crossings rose last year to the
highest level since 2017.
nearly 8 000 people entered the block
from belarus the eu accuses minsk of
flying in migrants from the middle east
and sending them illegally to the polish
border well dw talked to a psychologist
who is helping refugees who made it to
germany but are still traumatized by
their journey
a hug for comfort
psychologist maria kashonjak welcomes an
afghan family in berlin
they were trapped on the border between
belarus and poland
the mother lost her unborn child while
in a polish asylum center
they are still afraid
afraid of having to go back to their
country
afraid of having to go back to poland
afraid that they won't be understood
eu law says the family should apply for
asylum in poland the first member state
they entered
but the families say they spent weeks in
closed asylum centers there and lack of
medical assistance caused the woman's
miscarriage
they felt they had no choice but to go
to germany
we said that if you are deporting us
back to poland we will not go
you will have to send us back to
afghanistan but not poland because we
have very bad time from the poland very
bad experience i lost my child we had
nothing to eat we were
suffered a lot
maria kashonjak is helping the family
with their asylum case
she says the uncertainty is taking a
mental toll on them
it's probably one of the worst things
that can happen
putting them in a long limbo after very
traumatic experiences
they don't know what will happen to them
and their kids
it's like postponing their fears
she hopes that more stability will make
the therapy more effective
and that the family can come to terms
with their ordeal
well for more on this we're joined by
dw's emmanuela chaz she has reported
extensively on the migrant crisis across
europe and covered the developments on
the poland belarus border now asylum
seekers and refugees are clearly on the
front line when it comes to issues
around mental health what have you seen
uh well you know when you report from
the borders you see that people are
clearly in need of health care
especially mental health support the
world health organization estimates that
one out of five adults living in
conflict settings or being a displaced
person suffers from mental issues and of
course when i reported at the polish
at the border between poland and belarus
i could see people who had spent days
weeks on end alone in a forest having to
survive on drinking from ponds
eating
mushrooms or even leaves so you can
imagine the tall it takes on mental
health when i was reporting in central
mediterranean
i met i could talk to two people who
actually were in situations where they
almost lost their lives at sea they were
in increased risk at increased risk of
dying
in a very dangerous setting so of course
this takes
its toll on mental health they do face
also an uncertain future so at all
stages of the migration process
those persons actually are at acute risk
of suffering from mental health issues
and their struggle doesn't end once they
risk got to a safe country does it it
doesn't end indeed because uh once
they've arrived to what one could uh
deem a safe place germany for example
were there they face uncertainty they
also suffer from the lack of contact
with
relatives who remained in the
country of origin for example they
struggle to access health care even if
just because of the mental barrier the
the the language barrier they would have
at the very
beginning that's also integration and
settlement that is sometimes problematic
due to cultural differences religious uh
differences societal uh differences so
it's a long and struggling process for
asylum seekers
on an international level what's being
done to help prevent the displacement of
populations well
the there's a global action plan to
promote the health of refugees that is
being implemented by the world health
organization of course
the unhcr also tries to promote plans of
education of development in the
countries of origin in order to prevent
the causes for the displacement in the
first place but there's still very much
remaining to do emmanuel test thank you
very much
you